do you think do you think women should  be drafted in war that if i had a  country to protect and like an army i  won't draft no women i think you'd just  be inferior in war like if when you look  at it athletically in sports women are  worse at sports that's why they get paid  less but obviously they're better at  other skills such as child bearing and  looking after children so just do that  why do you need to be in the war okay  what do you think i think no i don't  think women should be i feel like um  there's just some things that men should  just just have for their for themselves  yeah what about you i think it depends  on what is being asked like what what  what the task is to be done the same  thing like men would have to do i think  maybe probably i can't hand-hand combat  like yeah my hand handcuffed probably  not because you wouldn't really i think  if they can meet the requirements needed  fitness wise then possibly but i know  that's not really possible